[Music]
J'son Phoenix hey Jay what's up how you
doing Dave
better than I deserve man how can I help
hey hey my father passed away last fall
and we're finally getting through all
the legal stuff and that sort of thing I
was left the house valued at about
$300,000 paid for all that kind of stuff
I'm debt free except for my personal
house I know about 180 that the big deal
of this is we've got some good family
friends that come out that winter
visitors over here and they're willing
to basically pay all the bills on the
house until I sell it I'm wondering if I
spit keep the house gonna let them pay
the bills on it because I think the
market Canadians are walking further
than what it has where should I sell it
now clean off my house for some
debt-free I'm trying to know what to do
how much of this decision is emotional
based on the fact that this was your
dad's house zero no come just wondering
if maybe you know a year two years from
Eric where the house
totally about 30 minutes from I am okay
if you had $300,000 in cash sitting in
the middle of your kitchen table would
you go buy this property for someone to
pay the expenses on for you while it
went up a little bit more money to fight
you know have somebody else pay the
bills on it and you know make a little
bit extra in a year or two if I woke up
in your shoes what I would do if I had
$3,000 set in the middle the table would
be I become debt-free I would use the
balance of the money to build some
wealth and you know invest it and as
that money grew I might pay cash for a
rental that actually produced an income
not that someone was just paying the
bills on I want the if I have $300,000
invested if I want to make 10% on that I
want to make $30,000 a year profit in my
get on thirty thousand three hundred
thousand dollars invested if I want to
make if I want to make eight percent on
it it would be thirty thousand but it
would be twenty four but so on you see
what I'm saying so you need to be making
twenty to thirty thousand dollars on a
three hundred thousand dollar investment
cash net after all expenses makes a lot
of sense and otherwise you be better off
having invested it in mutual funds and
not have to screw with it thank you hey
thanks for the call
sorry for the loss of your dad makes
these decisions tough and by the way
there is no shame in the nostalgia the
legacy the emotion of family property
entering into the decision that's part
of life this is personal finance and so
you might do something with the family
home that has been in the family for
four generations differently than you
would an exact same priced house that
you have no emotional connection to now
I don't have that much of a tendency
because I'm just I've done so many real
estate transactions that it kind of has
calloused me to it it's just a stupid
house I always say because it is there's
a stupid house on every corner you can
get stupid houses anywhere and people
get all twisted up and torqued up about
you know we got the perfect house out
ball there's no such thing come on
seriously it's like there's one person
in the entire world you're supposed to
marry and you missed it
oh come on give me a break fatalism so
it's a bad theology it's a bad
philosophy but it is normal and it is
reasonable mental health to say this
location means something special to me I
did something a few years ago that was
very weird my wife and I got in the car
and we drove to each of the properties
that we have ever lived in since we got
married
went up to the door and knocked on the
door one told the pea
what we were doing 100 percent of the
people let us in so we walked through
the little two-story duplex that we
lived in the first time when we first
got married then we walked through the
one we did not go into the one-bedroom
apartment after that because it's a
drug-infested neighborhood now it's
really dangerous and it probably wasn't
much better than but in our minds it's
different so we did drive down in there
didn't get a shot or anything so didn't
actually go into that apartment and then
we drove to the first house that we
bought and those people let us in and
boy that torn that thing all to crud
that's 17 dogs in the house it's stunk
and then we went to the next house that
we bought and lived in and the next
house that we bought that we lived in oh
and then I went to my childhood home and
knocked on the door and they'd let us in
too and that house had shrunk
considerably since I was a kid when I
was a kid that was a big house but it's
a hit it shrunk a lot it's uh I think
it's a thousand eighty square feet on
the main level and daddy and I built out
the rec room when I was a teenager with
studs on the walls and paneling from
Lowe's those little paneling nails Bend
and hit your fingers with a hammer and
but I got to go in that old house and
walk through it that was a strange
feeling that I had not been in it since
I was 16 years old so it's 40-something
years since I've been in the house and
but it was a very very interesting
little day we just rode around and
knocked on the door and told them and I
grew up in this house would is there any
chance I'd understand if you don't
because it's kind of weird was there any
chance you'd let me walk through and in
every case that they were home and
answered the door they let us come in we
used to own this house we used to live
here we first got married this was our
first house and so on this refers to
this house were living when our kids
were born and so on and but what it
reminds you is is that it's a stupid
house none of those properties made us
go oh it's an awesome property why do we
ever sell it we're in every case we're
like I'm so glad
we're out of there life is so much
better and that's not snobbish it's just
your life progresses hopefully hopefully
you're growing hopefully your wealth is
growing hopefully your expectations and
your goals and your vision for your life
is growing and if you're doing all of
that then it is just a stupid house but
there are some items that are not just a
financial transaction they're an
emotional transaction as well for
instance I've had couples in Financial
Peace University over the years they she
has a five or a ten thousand dollar
engagement ring and they've been married
three years so she's got a nice diamond
and she's like well you know we're
getting out of debt we're gizelle
intense I'm gonna sell my ring and I'm
like no no no no you just work an extra
few months and get yourself out of that
you keep your ring darling we don't do
that there's a few things like that that
you don't get rid of you know now
there's a couple times that stuff like
that is in your life and it's become an
idol and God is telling you to get rid
of it because he wants your brain in
your spirit to be freed up and you got a
little too much emotion tied up a little
too much spiritual I don't know our
emphasis tied up in that item a little
too much of that item brings me
happiness that's a little scary place to
be spiritually so sometimes those things
are pried away from your hands I've had
a couple of those in my life and that
means I honed them for the wrong reason
and I didn't home them they partially
honed my heart and so you've got to walk
through that stuff but all of this
discussion is part of personal finance
and that's where people in the financial
world gets so confused sometimes
and they give such bad advice sometimes
because they think it's only math yes
math is important we need to do math but
you'll often hear me walk through math
but math but in a different question or
a different thing that comes up here
because it's it is money and it is a
math equation
but there's more to it than that it's
more nuanced than that there's more
philosophy more theology more doctrine
applied to that decision-making then
there is simply math it's not just math
that's a naivete and you're missing out
on some wisdom when you only look at it
through the lens of math math will help
you and you ought to do math but that's
not the only way you make decisions in
personal finance